نبقى في مدينه خيرسون حيث نشر مراسل
لصحيفه
روسيه صورا لانزاله العلم الروسي امس من
فوق احدى البنايات الحكوميه في المدينه
واضاف صحفي روسيه من الاعلام الروسيه
اختفت من المباني الاداريه في المدينه وان
شبكه الهاتف الجوال والانترنت قطعت بشكل
كامل في الضفه اليسرى لنهر دينيرو
المقابله لمدينه خرسون
وفي روايه المقابله قال رئيس الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في خيرسون قال ان
قوتهم استعاده السيطره على 157 كلم مربعا
من اراضي المقاطعه خلال الاربع العشرين
ساعه الماضيه واضاف القيادي والعسكري
الاوكراني ان الخروج الروسيه المحتمل من
خيرسون هو نتيجه لفعل القوات الاوكرانيه
خصوصا انها دمرت طرق اللوجستيه ونظام
الدعم للقوات الروسيه التي لم يبقى لها
خيار سوى الفرار حسب تعبير
وعقب قرار موسكو سحب قواتها من الضفه
الغربيه لنهر ديني برو في خرسون قال رئيس
الاوكراني فولو دي مارسيليا قوته تتحرك
بحذر شديده من اجل تحرير خيرسون واراضي
اوكرانيه كامله وان من وصفهم بالعدو لا
يقدم هدايا وفقه تعبيره
لا داعي لها ومن دون مخاطر وذلك ارضنا
باكملها وباقل الخسائر هذا ما سيضمن تحرير
خلص وكل المدن
كما تهامه
مستشار مكتبي رئاسه الجمهوريه في كياب
اتهم روسيا بسعي لتدمير مدينه خيرسون
بالكامل وقال في تغريد ان الجيش الروسي
يسعى لجعل خير صور مدينه موت عبر تلغيم كل
شيء فيها وفق تعبيره